중국 전기차가 한국에 들어오는 걸 보면서 많은 분들이 이렇게 생각합니다.
그래도 현대차와 기아가 버티고 있는데 중국차가 한국 시장을 쉽게 흔들 수 있겠어?
맞습니다. 한국 자동차 시장은 쉽게 바뀌지 않을 겁니다.
현대차와 기아의 브랜드 파워도 강하고 공식 서비스 망도 이미 전국에 깔려 있으니 쉽지는 않겠죠.
그런데 오늘 우리가 봐야 할 건 자동차 판매가 아닙니다.
최근 중국의 자동차 정비 플랫폼 투우가 말레이시아에서 첫 해외 테스트를 시작했습니다.
처음 들으면 한국과는 상관없는 이야기처럼 보입니다.
말레이시아 정비소 시장에 중국 플랫폼이 들어온다는 게 왜 한국 문제냐는 생각이 들 수 있습니다.
그런데 지금 한국 상황을 보면 이 이야기가 완전히 남의 일처럼 보이지 않습니다.
BYD는 이미 한국 승용차 시장에 들어왔고 중국 전기차 브랜드들은 한국 시장을 계속 두드리고 있습니다.
2015년 한국 전기차 신규 등록은 22만 대를 넘었고
2016년에는 4월 중순에 이미 연간 신규 등록 10만 대를 넘겼습니다.
전기차 누적 등록도 100만 대를 돌파했죠.
여기서 중요한 포인트는 하나입니다.
중국 차가 한국에 늘어난다는 건 단순히 도로 위에 중국 브랜드 자동차가 많아진다는 뜻이 아닙니다.
그 차들을 관리할 장비 수요, 부품 수요, 배터리 점검 수요, 타이어 교체 수요가 같이 생긴다는 뜻이겠죠.
그리고 바로 그 지점에 투우 같은 플랫폼이 등장할 수 있다는 겁니다.
투우를 단순히 중국에서 구입할 수 있는 플랫폼이 아닙니다.
중국 차만 고치는 정비소로 보면 한국 시장에서의 확장 가능성을 과소평가하게 됩니다.
투우는 중국 차 전용 정비소가 아닙니다.
사용자가 앱에 차량 모델을 입력하면 그 차량에 맞는 타이어, 엔진 오일, 배터리, 브레이크, 부품, 정비 서비스를 연결해주는 플랫폼에 가깝습니다.
쉽게 말하면 BYD만 고치는 회사가 아니라는 겁니다.
차량별 부품 호환 데이터를 기반으로 여러 브랜드의 정비 수요를 연결할 수 있는 구조입니다.
2025년 말 기준으로 투우의 부품 데이터베이스는
1,150만 개 SKU, 330개 이상 브랜드, 8만 3천 개 이상 차종을 커버했습니다.
이 정도면 특정 브랜드 전용 정비소라기보다
자동차 정비와 부품을 앱 안에서 연결하는 시스템에 가깝습니다.
그래서 한국이 가장 먼저 봐야 할 건 중국 차 점유율이 커져야만 투우가 들어온다가 아닙니다.
중국 차는 투우가 한국에 들어올 수 있는 가장 자연스러운 명분일 뿐입니다.
하지만 실제 확장 대상은 중국 차 정비에만 머물지 않을 가능성이 매우 큽니다.
처음에는 중국 전기차 언어에 불편을 해결하는 서비스처럼 들어올 수 있습니다.
중국 차를 산 소비자들은 자연스럽게 이런 고민을 하게 됩니다.
어디에 정비를 맡겠지, 부품은 제대로 구할 수 있을지, 가격은 적정한지 알기 어렵기 때문입니다.
이때 투우 같은 플랫폼이 내세울 수 있는 메시지는 굉장히 단순합니다.
차량 모델을 입력하면 맞는 부품과 가격을 미리 확인할 수 있습니다.
가까운 제휴 정비소를 예약하고 정비 이력까지 앱에서 관리할 수 있습니다.
물론 한국 소비자도 이미 이런 경험에 익숙합니다.
타이어를 온라인에서 비교하고 차량 번호로 배터리를 조회하고 엔진 오일 가격을 미리 확인하는 서비스는 이미 있습니다.
스피드메이트나 티스테이션 같은 국내 서비스도 차량 정보 기반 조회와 예약 기능을 제공합니다.
그러니까 투우식 모델이 완전히 낯선 방식은 아닙니다.
오히려 한국 소비자에게는 예약 기능을 제공합니다.
익숙한 인터페이스를 더 넓은 범위로 확장한 형태로 보일 수 있습니다.
문제는 여기서 시작됩니다.
처음에는 저렴한 가격과 쉬운 예약으로 브랜드 인지도를 높일 수 있습니다.
중국차 오너들이 먼저 쓰고 그 다음 가격에 민감한 소비자들이 쓰고 이후에는 타이어, 배터리, 브레이크, 소모품 같은 반복 정비 영역으로 넓어질 수 있습니다.
투우 입장에서 한국 정비 시장 전체를 처음부터 바꿀 필요는 없습니다.
소비자가 자주 찾는 정비 항목부터 앱으로 옮기면 됩니다.
이 지점에서 현대차와 기아 이야기가 나올 수밖에 없습니다.
한국에서 가장 큰 자동차 시장은 결국 현대차와 기아입니다.
그래서 투우 jaktn 플랫폼이 한국에서 의미 있는 규모로 성장하려면, 언젠가는 현대차와 기아 차량의 반복 정비 수요를 볼 수밖에 없습니다.
현대차와 기아 차량의 반복 정비 수요를 볼 수밖에 없습니다.
물론 현대차와 기아의 공식 서비스 망을 바로 대체하기는 어려울 것입니다.
블루엔즈와 오토큐 같은 이미 강한 네트워크를 가지고 있고, 고정 수리 체계도 탄탄합니다.
네트워크를 갖고 있고 보증 수리 체계도 탄탄합니다.
하지만 모든 정비가 공식 서비스 센터에서만 이루어지는 것은 아닙니다.
타이어나 배터리, 간단 점검 같은 영역은 소비자가 가격과 편의성을 많이 봅니다.
공식 서비스 센터에 가기 불편하거나 가격이 부담스럽거나
더 가까운 정비소를 찾고 싶은 소비자도 꽤 많습니다.
국내 자동차 정비업체는 2025년 1분기 기준 3만6천개가 넘습니다.
블루엔진은 700개가 조금 넘는 수준이고
기아오토큐도 직영센터와 협력사를 합쳐 수백개 규모입니다.
공식망이 강한 건 맞지만 여전히 수많은 중소정비업체로 나뉘어 있습니다.
이런 시장에서 플랫폼은 모든 정비소를 직접 소유할 필요가 없습니다.
기존 정비소를 제우점으로 연결하고 가격과 예약과 결제를 앱에서 처리하면 됩니다.
여기서 독립카센터의 고민이 시작됩니다.
처음에는 제우정비소가 이득을 볼 수는 있습니다.
플랫폼이 고객을 보내주고 부품 조달을 도와주고 예약을 만들어주기 때문입니다.
하지만 시간이 지나면 플랫폼 밖에 있는 정비소는
가격 비교와 예약 경쟁에서 불리해질 수 있습니다.
부품 유통업자도 영향을 받을 수밖에 없죠.
투우식 모델은 부품 공급망과 정비소 네트워크를 함께 묶습니다.
고객이 앱에서 결제하고 플랫폼이 수수료를 제외한 뒤
정비소에 정산하는 구조가 되면 정비소는 일을 하지만
고객 데이터와 결제 데이터는 플랫폼에 쌓입니다.
부품도 마찬가지입니다.
플랫폼이 표준 SK와 가격을 만들고 여러 공급자를 직접 연결하면
기존 중간 유통의 역할은 줄어들 수 있습니다.
소비자 입장에서는 처음에 이 변화가 나쁘지 않게 보일 가능성이 매우 큽니다.
오히려 더 편할 수도 있겠죠.
한국에서 자동차 정비는 여전히 소비자가 판단하기 어려운 영역입니다.
실제로 자동차 정비 관련 피해구제 신청을 보면
정비 분량과 부당 청구가 큰 비중을 차지합니다.
그래서 이런 시장에서는 가격을 미리 보여준다는 말이 강하게 들릴 수밖에 없습니다.
그래서 투우 같은 앱 기반 정비 플랫폼은
처음에는 소비자에게 편리한 서비스로 받아들여질 가능성이 큽니다.
하지만 장기적으로 더 중요한 건 가격이 아닙니다.
어떤 차가 언제 정비를 받는지, 어떤 부품이 자주 교체되는지,
소비자가 어떤 가격에서 선택을 하는지,
어떤 정비소가 어떤 작업을 처리하는지에 대한 데이터입니다.
이 데이터가 반복해서 쌓이면 플랫폼은 장비 수요를,
예측할 수 있습니다.
부품 재고를 미리 준비할 수도 있고,
차량별로 필요한 정비를 추천할 수도 있고,
소비자가 다시 정비를 받을 시점까지 계산할 수 있습니다.
결국 투우의 핵심은 중국차를 정비하느냐가 아닙니다.
차량별 부품 호환 데이터와 정비 서비스를 앱 안에서 연결할 수 있다는 점입니다.
처음에는 중국 전기차 정비를 이유로 들어올 수 있습니다.
하지만 데이터가 쌓이면 현대차, 기아, 테슬라, 수입차의 반복 정비 영역으로
기아, 테슬라, 수입차의 반복 정비 영역으로
넓어질 가능성이 생깁니다.
물론 지금 당장 투우가 한국에 들어온다는 공식 발표는 없습니다.
말레이시아 사례를 한국에 그대로 대입해서
한국 정비업이 곧바로 흔들린다고 말하는 것도 과장입니다.
하지만 방향은 분명히 봐야겠죠, 우리가.
중국은 이제 자동차만 수출하지 않습니다.
전기차만 수출하지도 않습니다.
가격 경쟁 방식, 앱 기반 예약 방식, 부품 데이터 관리 방식,
정비소를 연결하는 운영 모델까지 함께 수출하고 있습니다.
말레이시아는 그 첫 번째 테스트에 가깝습니다.
그리고 한국은 자동차 보유 대수가 많고
전기차 전환이 빨라지고 있고
중국 전기차 브랜드가 이미 들어오기 시작한 시장입니다.
중국차가 한국에서 일정 수준 이상으로 쌓이면
정비와 부품 수요도 함께 커지겠죠.
그때 중국식 정비 플랫폼이 들어오지 말라는 법은 없습니다.
결국 이 영상의 핵심은 단순합니다.
중국차 점유율이 커져야만 투우가 들어온다는 이야기가 아닙니다.
중국차는 진입 명분이 될 수는 있겠죠.
그런데 실제 확장 대상은 한국 자동차 정비 시장 전체의 반복 정비 수요일 수 있습니다.
처음에는 소비자에게 싸고 편한 서비스로 보일 수 있습니다.
그 다음에는 제휴 정비소가 늘어날 수 있습니다.
이후에는 차량별 부품 데이터와 정비 이력이 쌓입니다.
그리고 마지막에는 소비자가 정비소를 찾는 방식 자체가 앱 중심으로 바뀔 수 있습니다.
결국 한국 자동차 시장에서 지금 봐야 할 질문은
중국 전기차가 얼마나 팔리느냐가 전부일까요?
아니면 그 뒤에 따라오는 정비, 부품, 결제, 데이터 시장까지 같이 봐야 할까요?
중국차가 도로 위에 늘어나는 순간, 진짜 경쟁은 차를 파는 순간에 끝나지 않을 수 있습니다.
그 차를 누가 관리하고, 어떤 부품을 연결하고, 어떤 데이터를 쌓고,
어떤 앱이 소비자의 다음 정비를 결정하게 되는가.
바로 그 지점에서 한국 자동차 정비 시장의 다음 변화가 시작될 수 있습니다.
영상 시청해주셔서 감사합니다.